Oh what is going on YouTube you know
every new year we all set goals for
ourselves but for some reason every time
the year ends we all seem to fall short
that go and I kind of figured it out you
know what that is
ain't nobody encouraging you in the
proper ways my friends [ __ ] plane
that is a loud-ass plane the most common
New Year's goal that everyone has and
everybody knows it is weight loss I
don't know what I'm saying
wait so today I'm about to be that angel
upon your shoulder that's gonna help you
out to the whole year that's right
people I'm gonna help y'all and test
that ass all the way to the road booth
said listen something we got we know
what it is
LGI baby let it get joke fat ass in the
gym that's right put the double
cheeseburger down get the conscience off
in double chin and get to moving every
year to tell you stuff you're gonna do
it but you know this year you know what
you going to fight you will look like a
half naked Greek god mixed with the sex
side yeah I don't know what the [ __ ]
that is but hold your kids cuz you might
look hey look at me you're tired of
being fat aren't you tired of going to
the beach with your skinny ass friends
but then [ __ ] asses be like come here
just get in the water
don't worry about what you look like
come here don't worry about what I look
like
but guess what you gonna be one of those
skinny [ __ ] this year man you don't
look so good every time you walk by a
group of teens they gonna pop a boner
and act like they got a stomachache so
nobody knows they got one just hey Jimmy
let's go cool why not oh oh no no I
can't no i'ma just stay where I got
stomachache so I'm going to stay right
here I'm gonna just walk like this
aren't you tired according the clothes
start and wonder why I should look good
but look [ __ ] up when you went like
that cardigan look good on that
mannequin but when you want it [ __ ] look
like a v-neck wetsuit you're tired of
having to wake up looking at the mirror
and feeling bad about yourself seeing
all these skinny and dicks walking away
with your wig you got to tell yourself
you don't want that 40 piece McNuggets
for $8.99 you want to go to be on the
phone yo McNuggets bow free kick that
[ __ ] pop some [ __ ] iron and lose
those man titties aren't you tired of
trying to figure out let your kneecaps
and your ankles in it's hard isn't it
saying no to food food is always been
there for you food ever yelled at you
who never called you fat who never told
you and critics before you go ahead and
shovel all that food into your face you
need to go ahead and ask yourself a few
questions
Phil give me that 14 cheeseburger bacon
goes with everything doesn't mean it
should do you need to drink the Sun with
every meal you want some fat-free water
when you walk down the street there's an
ice cream man look at you like you just
won the lottery
anyway those of you out there that may
not even know that you're saying but you
fat as [ __ ]
you want the first thing that people say
when they're in denial boom oh girl my
future [ __ ] you're closer to shrink you
explode it trust me I get the
insecurities that come along with
feeling bad about how you physically
feel is one of the worst feelings on her
I don't know about me I used to be 285
pounds Danny at 6 feet tall and I was
miserable during that time I was going
through a lot of things in food and I
had like an emotional connection I know
a lot of you skinny people out there who
don't really understand food like I do
you know you just don't get it but well
[ __ ] you that's how it was I think a
problem with a lot of us in the reason
why we can't lose weight is because not
only do we love the way food tastes we
love the way food makes us feel look how
I see you got two options obviously one
get a proper diet stay active and lose
some weight and your reasonings behind
it it could be anything it could be
vanity for crying out loud if you want
to lose weight so you can look good
go ahead and do a plan if that's what it
takes then use that as motivation and
rock that [ __ ] out and obviously if
vanity isn't the right motivation for
you then do it for the health better
business you'll live a lot longer you'll
sleep a lot better you can you feel
that are about to sell second option if
you're offended you're not gonna do [ __ ]
and lose weight you have no right to
complain go suck a dinosaur dick my fat
brothers and sisters this is something
that you want point you have to wrap
your head around when you hold yourself
accountable and you stop for a second
and stop twenty fingers at everybody
else but you this is where it begins you
are not that because of your family you
are not that because of all your
restaurants out there you are fat
because you chose to do is to yourself
despite the fact that there are other
factors that it forced you you can do it
I'm telling you right now you can do it
nobody else is stopping you but yourself
look at this video a [ __ ] million
times if you have to but go out there
and [ __ ] do it look to hell with it
being a new year tomorrow's a new day
I'm telling you right now that you got
this let's get
wanna cut that [ __ ] is getting brighter
and just [ __ ] mount with the thing
this video is gonna look crazy cuz it's
gonna be bright sometime that night
[ __ ] Sun make up your mind if your
shirt got any more tired of that button
on your shirt will come out like a
machine gun